انت في حياتك الخاصه وعلى مواقع التواصل
وانت في العمل
منفصلان لكن يبدو ان الاول قد يضعك في
ورطه وفي الثانيه
دراسه شامله اعتمدت على خبراء
وجدت بان ظهور الموظف على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بشكل يمكن ان يعد غير لائق باتي
يعرض الموظفين للمسائله والمحاسبه ولتشويه
الصوره في العمل الخبراء يعتبر وان خوض
التحديات التي يقوم بها اشخاص من اجل
الكسب المزيد كالرقص او الاكل قد يضعه
موضعا يقلل من شانه الاخرى بعض الموظفين
كالعلم والتربوي والقانون والاعلام وغيرها
من الوظائف هم قدوه لمجتمعاتهم وبالتالي
الرقص على تيك توك على كل حال سالنا الناس
في مصر كيف يؤثر نشاطك على مواقع التواصل
على صوره في العمل
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان هي ما بتقصرش لان طبعا بالنسبه
لنا احنا كمان قديم يعني متعودين على
عادات معينه ومش مش يعني
السوشيال ميديا كثير قوي يعني
بسيطه او بنقرا او بنتصفح
شنال
مش اكثر
مختلفه عن شخصيتي في الشغل يعني
ممكن يؤثر عليك على شغلك ما ينفعش طبعا اي
حاجه لازم تبقى حاذر انت ممكن تشير
النهارده حاجه
مع زميله لك مع زميل لك مع مدير ليك في
العمل اي كومنت مش لطيف ممكن ياثر طبعا
لازم لما تكون دقيق لان انا اكيد قدوه
للناس اللي معي كويس لان دوت انعكاس او
صورتي قدام الناس اللي انا باشتغل معهم
لازم اكون بشير حاجات همم بتفيد الناس
حاجات كويسه ما تبقاش الحاجات ديت خارجه
لا اكون دقيق جدا في كل حاجه بشيرها والله
انا بحكم ان انا كبير في السن ما فيش ما
فيش حاجه تقدر تاثر على شغلي لان شغلي بقى
اصيل و ثابت ونتائجه بالنسبه ليا كده كده
المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ده بس يعني كده
شويه وقت فراغ نعمل كده كده الواقع العملي
حاجه ثانيه خالص
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سامي يسعد صباحك ونورنا من جديد صباح
النور والسرور
غير لائق للموظف قد يمكن ان يعرضه للمساله
اكيد في جهات عمل لما توضح عند موظف جديد
توقع على وثيقه اخلاقيات العمل والقيام
والسلوك المهني هذه اذا انت مثلت الجهه
بتمثلها داخليا وخارجيا فاذا سويت اشياء
فقط فيها جهه العمل او سويت فيها شيء يضر
جهات العمل او سمعتك اكيد بياثر عليك
وممكن يكون في اجراءات قانونيه عليك يعني
حرام يعني كان في قاسي جوابك من بدايه انه
اكيد يعني اليس من حق كل انسان ان يعيش
حريه خارج جدران هذا العمل هو يمتلك
حسابات خاصه وشخصيه ليست باسم المؤسسه
وباسم الشركه صحيح صحيح بس لكن انا تكلمت
عليها نقطه واحده اذا انتقدت جهه العمل
لان انت تشتغل فيها بطريقه غير صحيه او
غير صحيحه هذا بس اذا انت عندك حساب تواصل
الاجتماعي تتكلم عن نفسك تسوي شيء تسوق
لنفسك لمنتج معين تضحك الناس شيء ايجابي
في نقد حتى ايجابي بالعكس انت توصل رساله
طيب انا هذه السؤال ثانيه يعني ما دام
نادين معه فانا ضد طيب الى اي ماده هناك
بعض الموظفين المفروض يكونوا قدوه
لمجتمعاتهم يعني وظيفتهم تحكم عليهم بذلك
وانه همم مسؤولياتهم تتعدى مواقع الهبل
اكيد الحين انت لما تداوم تتمثل سمعتك همم
تمثل الجهه تمثل التربيه اللي اشتغلت فيها
فانت تسوق لنفسك وكل مكان منصبك اكبر كلمه
تكون يعني المسؤوليه اكبر والناس ما تقتدي
فيك يعني كيف انا مثلا اكون رسمي جدا
بالعمل
وساعد الناس وكاستمر مثلا يعني اتكلم خدمه
عملاء وخارج العمل اسوي اشياء مثلا همم
غريبه همم خطا ممكن اسوق السياره بسرعه
كبيره مثلا اصور طب هذا يعني مثلا
تسويه خارج العمل اكيد هياثر عليك
حتى تعامل اذا قررت من احترامك لنفسك قدام
الناس وانت موظف خدمه عملاء اكيد الناس
هتتعامل معك بطريقه مغايره طيب سامي يعني
انا من الناس اللي لسنه سابقا يعني كان
عندي حسابين واحد برايفت وواحد بابليك
برايفت ما بيعرفوا عنه كل الناس وبعيش
حياتي بكل اريحيه فيه والطلب لك اللي يخص
العمل هل هنا يمكن ان تتعرض للمسائله اذا
اذا ما نشرت على البرايفت امور معينه وحدا
وشها عني كله يعتمد قوانين الدوله من دوله
الى دوله تختلف قوانين جهات العمل ايضا
يعني حسب الوظيفه هل هي وظيفه حساسه مثلا
وظيفه عاديه في جهات همم ما في داعي انك
تتوقعي مثلا سلوكيات واخلاق العمل في
عندهم عادي ما عندك حياتك الشخصيه انت حر
فيها فيعتمد على وظيفه وعلى يعني جهه
العمل انت تشتغل فيها فما اتوقع لكن في
جهات عمل تطلب حسب الوظيفه حسب الوظيفه
همم
حسابات التواصل الاجتماعي عندك هل انت
مناسب كان الوظيفه اللي موجوده عندنا
حسابك همم تسويقه مناسب لنا ولا لا في
جهات نعم في جهات لا سامي يعني في ساعات
موظفين اسطمونه يعني بتكون عندهم سلوكيات
على مواقع التواصل تسيء لسمعه وظيفتهم
تقلل من شانهم وتحطم القدرهم في هذه
الحاله ما هي حدود سلوكيات الموظف على
مواقع التواصل همم كل واحد يمثل نفسه يمثل
بلده يمثل الجهه الي اشتغل فيها يمثل
التربيه اللي ترباها في البيت فاولا
واخيرا الناس ما بتحترمك اذا انت محترم
نفسك
سواء بالعمل سواء بيت سواء مع زوجتك عيالك
مع المجتمع فانت اولا واخيرا سفير لنفسك
لوطنك لدولتك لاهلك فلازم الاشياء حتى لو
سويت اشياء مضحكه عادي مش غلط يعني وفي
ناس تسوي اشياء ايجابيه يعني مثلا في ناس
اشخاص اشتغلوا على نفسهم طوروا مهاراتهم
لما يطلع من جهه العمل يسووا اشياء مفيده
للدوله لجهه العمل قالوا يستخدمهم عارفين
حفل بجيهات معينه يسوقوا للجهه اللي هم
شغالين فيها بما كان مختلفه فلها ايجابيه
ولها سلبي
كبير من الموظفين انتشرت هذه الظاهره
مؤخرا بيفرضوا حالهم على السوشيال ميديا
يعني بيتايتل اكبر وحجم اكبر بكثير مما
يقومون به يعني احنا طابخينها سوا يعني زي
ما الواحد بيقول يعني هل كمان هذا الامر
ولو انهم ما بحكوا بامور اخلاقيه تمس يعني
في الشكل اللائق ولكن بافرضوا نفسهم بصوره
مغايره تماما عما يقوم به داخل العمل هل
ايضا يحاسبون لا اكيد طبعا لا همم يعني
هذا شيء وهذا شيء ثاني اذن يعني في في
قانون بالدوله موجود همم ودائما يكون في
تنبيه وتنويه على وسائل همم التواصل
الاجتماعي الاشياء اللي تتكلم فيها او
اشياء اللي المفروض تتجنبونها والمحاسبات
والعقبات بس اذا انت مثلا بالجهه ستايل
معين وخارج للجهه ستايل معين فكاه هي ضحك
تسوي اكتيفيتي تسوي اشياء مختلفه طالما
انت يعني في ناس ممكن تتابعك في ناس يعني
لها قبول انها تابعه كلها الحق نوال تابعك
وانا واخيرا تمثل نفسك سواء بتضحك الناس
تبقى تنشر معلومه سلبيه معلومه ايجابيه
فالناس في ناس هتسمعك وهتمشي بكلامك في
ناس يمكن تسمع وتطنش في ناس يمكن تشوفك
شوي وبعدين ما تتابعك تشوف المحتوى اللي
عندك هل هو مفيد او لا طب قلت انه جهه
العمل همم تعمل على همم ان يوقع الموظف
على وثيقه سلوكيات اخلاقيات العمل طيب في
هذه الحاله ما هي طبيعه العقوبات في حال
خاله في الموضع يعتمد يعتمد كل جهه منصبك
حساس جهه حساسه جهه عاديه همم وانا واخيرا
انت مثلا موظف همم انا بجهه العمل انتقد
في جهات قنوات رسميه تنتقدها بس طلعت على
السوشيال ميديا انت حطيتها على تويتر
والله كذا كذا
فانت مش يعني ما كنت ما كان عندك انتقادنا
روح على الجهات الرسميه اذا ما هذا في
جهات اخرى يعني ممكن يتعرض المسائله اذا
انت قدها بطريقه سلبيه وبس سمعت المؤسسه
لانه مؤمن على اسرار المؤسسه صورت
بالمؤسسه مثلا ممنوع التصوير مثلا في
اشياء معينه ورحت نشرتها طيب انت عارف ان
انت ممنوع تنشر الاشياء هاي او ممنوع
تصورها صور زملائك صورت مديرك انتقدت
مديرك بطريقه سلبيه في المجتمع مثلا
حطيتها على وصاله للتواصل الاجتماعي زين
في جهات يعني تقدر تنتقد تقدر تعبر عن
وجهه نظرك عن الاشياء اللي مثلا اذا انت
مهم حقك تكلمهم يا جماعه الخير همم وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ممكن تكون الحل بس ممكن
الحل ينجذب عليك يعني
اكيد طبعا جزيلا الاجسام يا ابو حاتم خبير
ومدير موارد بشريه